sein arbeitsort der vatikan sein amt
präsident der finanzaufsichtsbehörde des
vatikans seine aufgabe kampf gegen
geldwäsche und gegen die finanzierung
des terrorismus
das ist der steckbrief von rené brülhart
rené brülhart ist ein schweizer jurist
in seiner aufgabe direkt papst
franziskus unterstellt herr pröll halt
finanzen geld und vatikan das klingt
nach einer brisanten mischung nach einem
himmelfahrtskommando also der himmel ist
da
ob es eine fahrt dorthin ist wird sich
herausstellen aber auf jeden fall eine
spezielle und auch eine sehr spannende
mischung
sie sind präsident dieser autorität die
informationen finanziell f also einer
aufsichtsbehörde
was machen sie eigentlich genau ich
glaube da muss man auch ein bisschen
zurück schauen woher wir kommen also
heutzutage sind wir sozusagen die
zuständige behörde in der bekämpfung von
möglichen illegalen finanzaktivitäten
das war nicht immer so sondern was wir
heute sind einerseits aufsichtsbehörde
ansatz auch geldwäsche meldestelle das
hat sich eigentlich in den letzten zwei
jahren entwickelt so wenn wir ein
bisschen ihn sozusagen die geschichte
dieser behörde hineingehen
dann haben sie die anfänge das geht
zurück auf ende 2010 als der damalige
papst benedikt ein entsprechendes
sozusagen ein päpstlichen erlass ein
sogenanntes motu proprio erlassen hat um
die behörde aufzusetzen und auch um das
erste geldwäschegesetz des vatikans zu
statuieren
damals aber war es eigentlich
ausschließlich oder weiß angedacht
ausschließlich eine geldwäsche
meldestelle als solches zu haben mit ich
würde mal sagen mit sehr beschränkten
aufsichtsrechtlichen tätigkeiten und
kompetenz das heißt die behörde wurde
schon unter dem vorgänger von papst fans
gefunden
das erstaunt ja man denkt eben papst
franziskus der reformer der aufräumer im
vatikan
sie sind dann 2012 da hingekommen inside
2014 jetzt als präsident dieser
aufsichtsbehörde ihnen untersteht auch
die sogenannte vatikanbank darüber
wollen wir auch sprechen
dazu sehen wir jetzt einen kurzen
ausschnitt aus der tagesschau vom elften
juli 2013 schweizer die für das wohl und
die sicherheit im vatikan sorgen
die gardisten machen das seit über 500
jahren
rené brülhart erst seit wenigen monaten
der gebürtige freiburger soll im
kirchenstaat all jene aufspüren die mit
schwarzgeld und geldwäsche ihr unwesen
treiben
ganz generell sind wie die zuständige
behörde zur bekämpfung der geldwäsche
oder generell der missbrauchsbekämpfung
in finanzplatz in den finanz sachen
doppelfunktion in dem sinne dass wir
einerseits die geldwäsche meldestelle
sind aber auch die aufsichtsbehörde als
solches zu melden gibt es momentan viel
denn mit seinen finanzaktivitäten ist
der vatikan schwer ins zwielicht geraten
der letzte skandal handelt von diesem
monsignore einem ehemaligen
rechnungsprüfer am heiligen stuhl
500.000 euro hat er sich in der
vatikanbank auszahlen lassen um laut
staatsanwaltschaft rom einen noch
größeren geldtransfer in der schweiz zu
organisieren
20 millionen euro in bar per
privatflugzeug von lugano nach neapel
der monsignore sitzt in
untersuchungshaft der generaldirektor
der vatikanbank und sein stellvertreter
sind zurückgetreten
rené brülhart muss jetzt mit dem neuen
bank präsidenten dafür sorgen dass
solche geldschiebereien künftig nicht
mehr möglich sind
ich hab präsentiert die behörde er
repräsentiert das finanzinstitut
wir haben ein gemeinsames ziel einen
absolut sauberen vatikan zu haben ein
absolut sauber vatikan rené brülhart das
war vor knapp zwei jahren ist das ziel
erreicht
es ist ein prozess und ich würde hier
nie irgendwo in absoluten worten
sprechen sondern ich glaube es ist
wirklich ein ein prozess und
insbesondere auch verbunden mit einem
system das wir erarbeitet haben und wenn
wir zurückdenken was sozusagen in den
letzten drei vier jahren geschaffen
worden ist
angefangen mit einer komplett neuen
rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen mit einem
neuen gesetzgebung einerseits
andererseits dann auch die situation aus
solches die neu geschaffen worden sind
oder die entsprechend ausgebaut worden
sind wie auch die behörde zuständig bin
die wir zu einer vollumfänglichen
integrierten aufsichtsbehörde
umgewandelt haben auch mit den
entsprechenden notwendigen konsequenzen
aber dann auch das ganze system mit
leben zu füllen
nicht nur sozialen rahmenbedingungen zu
schaffen sondern wirklich auch das
entsprechend zu leben die internationale
zusammenarbeit auf zu setzen und dann
auch die möglichkeiten zu haben die
instrumente in die hand zu nehmen wo und
leider dort wo so zahn finanzaktivitäten
stattfinden gibt es zum teil auch
gewisse missbrauchsfälle die dann auch
entsprechend zu handhaben und zu
bekämpfen
missbrauchsfälle in einer wird eben
genannt bevor wir zu dieser vatikanbank
kommen dieser nunzio carano das war zwar
kurz nach ihrer nach ihrem beginn aber
trotzdem sozusagen unter ihren haken
eine große summe bargeld eine geplante
transaktion von 20 millionen euro
immerhin aus der schweiz nach italien
waren sich schockiert ich glaube nicht
dass man schockiert ist sondern man
schaut sich die fakten an und nimmt sich
dann sozusagen den entsprechenden sachen
an und
der verlor netz hier sozialen in details
zu gehen ich hoffe sie haben verständnis
dafür kann man sagen das war eigentlich
eine der ersten schritte wo man auch
gesehen hat dass das system funktioniert
also sprich das den spenden sprechenden
verdachts mitteilungen erstattet worden
sind das maß behörde es entsprechend
analysiert hat und dann auch die
notwendigen konsequenzen gezogen hat
wie zum beispiel eigentlich das erste
oder allererste rechtshilfeersuchen das
dann vom vatikan an die italienischen
behörden gestellt worden ist also das
ist etwas neues oder das interne leute
aus dem vatikan sozusagen danach
überstellt werden der italienischen
justiz einerseits aber auch die
internationale zusammenarbeit dass das
war ja eigentlich etwas wenn man die
jahre zurückschaut wo ein das heißt die
rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen gefehlt
haben dass man überhaupt sozusagen die
möglichkeit gehabt hätte dort auch
aktive pro aktiv zusammenzuarbeiten aber
dass dann auch entsprechend zu tun
und dieser fall hat eigentlich sehr wohl
verdeutlicht dass nicht nur darüber
gesprochen wird sondern dass auch
gehandelt wird und dass man dort dann
auch aktiv eine mögliche
missbrauchsbekämpfung vornimmt dieser
nun sogar an oder sie seien vatikan
interner hochrangiger mitarbeiter
wo ist er heute sitzt er ein
italienischer staatsbürger hat wo er
sich heute befindet heute am sonntag bin
ich überfragt aber es gab entsprechende
verfahren in italien wo auch eine
entsprechende verurteilung stattgefunden
hat in aller fairness hier nicht im
zusammenhang mit geldwäsche sondern wenn
ich nicht ganz falsch lägen zusammenhang
mit einer möglichen verleumdung
wie es von seiten das hat die kante
dieser angelegenheit weiter gehen wird
wird man noch schauen müssen aber
gewisse sachen sind dort noch
entsprechenden laufen
sie sind die aufsichtsbehörde dann die
jurisdiktion ist er wieder eine andere
geschichte diese vatikanbank wir haben
ein bild gesehen in diesem kurzen
filmbeitrag
unscheinbar festungs turm kleine
schalterhalle
sie betonen immer ein das ist nicht
eigentlich eine bank was ist dieses ist
ditto bälle die religion ohne dieses
oriana sisters eine räumlichkeit new
york saturn es auch hatte mal eine
andere funktion aber darauf müssen wir
nicht näher eingehen
ich glaube es gibt viele viele mythen
über dieses sogenannte oder was im
allgemeinen sprachgebrauch als
vatikanbank betitelt wird ob es eine
bank ist sei dahingestellt darauf können
wir noch kurz eingehen
es gibt auch viele geschichten es gibt
auch eine große vergangenheit
wenn wir zurückdenken ein bisschen älter
als 70 jahre als von daher keine mal alt
institutionen wie zum beispiel schweizer
privatbank not was auch immer aber auch
sehr viel eigentlich ein mystiker
verbunden auch mit ich würde sagen mit
missverständnissen die hier auch
vorherrschen
wenn ja wenn wir wenn wir konkret und
ich spreche über heute ich spreche nicht
über die vergangenheit aber wenn wir das
heutige anschauen bzw
wie es sich in den letzten zwei drei
jahren auch entsprechend entwickelt hat
ist wahrscheinlich nicht ganz korrekt
dass man von einer baum spricht also
einerseits wollen wir an von der
aufsetzung als solches das als solches
ist ein einziges institut hat einen
einzigen sitz im vatikan als solches es
gibt keine zweigstellen sei dass in
italien in der schweiz oder sonst
irgendwo punkt 1.2 sinn und zweck dieses
institutes
es ist kein kommerzielles finanzinstitut
es war auch nie angedacht dass ein
solches werden würde sondern wie es der
name schon sagt sein institut für
religiöse werke dieses istituto per le
opere di religione genug gehen
und die frage ist dann wie wird es
verwendet bzw bis zum teil auch
verwendet worden
und wenn wir sozusagen die heutige
struktur anschauen von personen oder von
instituten und von organisationen die
die möglichkeit überhaupt haben dort
eine geschäftsbeziehung einzugehen oder
sondern auch zu leben muss man sehr wohl
differenzieren sie können nicht einfach
irgendwo in porta santana oder beim
anderen eingang des vatikans
einmarschieren
ich würde jetzt gerne hier eine
geschäftsbeziehung also ich kann da
nicht einfach ein konto sie müssen sich
sehr viel mühe geben aber
höchstwahrscheinlich nein nein unter den
heutigen umständen nein wäre das nicht
mehr wer kann denn hier geld lagern oder
kirchenleute oder ja also einerseits
sozusagen geistliche dann auch
kirchliche institutionen
sie habe norden sie haben nonnen sie
haben mönche und sie haben auch
mitarbeiter des vatikans als solches die
die möglichkeit haben eine entsprechende
geschäftsbeziehung einzugehen
viel bargeld ist im umlauf erklärt sich
dass dadurch dass viele weltregionen von
der katholischen kirche sozusagen mit
geld bedient werden für ich weiß nicht
hilfsprojekte oder so wie eben gar keine
transaktion möglich sind was man muss
vorschieben das sozialen der ganze
bargeldverkehr in den letzten jahren
massiv abgenommen hat und das aus
verschiedenen gründen einerseits weil
auch die die finanzsysteme oder die
finanz zeiten in der welt ein bisschen
anders zu funktionieren begonnen haben
und das auch mit bargeld ein bisschen
problematisch geworden ist andererseits
aber auch im zusammenhang mit den
entsprechenden kontrollen die aufgesetzt
worden sind aber zurückgehen auf ihr auf
ihre frage selbstverständlich oder sie
haben einerseits haben sie die
geografischen lage also sprich vor
leute aus siders aus oder geistliche zum
beispiel aus afrika oder asien in den
vatikan kommen sozusagen dann auch das
geld nach hause bringen wollen oder in
die nähe des papstes wo sie keine
funktionierenden finanzsystem haben also
auch wenn sie gerne zum beispiel eine
banküberweisung vornehmen möchten geht
das nicht oder haben sie gar keine
möglichkeit weil sie keinen
entsprechenden zugriff haben wo sie
haben auch entsprechende spendengelder
oder sie haben auch kollekten in der
kirche zentrale es gibt einige gründe
die dafür sprechen und das wird sich in
den nächsten jahren auch nicht
wahnsinnig ändern was das geld betrifft
was unser ansatz ist schon auch unser
anliegen diesbezüglich war zu verstehen
und nachvollziehen zu können woher
dieses bargeld kommt und der passt haben
also ein bisschen flapsig gesagt ja
petrus hatte auch keine bagger apostel
was brauchen wir diese vatikan
sogenannte vatikanbank könnte man sich
einfach schließen
schauen wir vielleicht ganz kurz auf die
dienstleistungen die das ihr als solches
anbietet und das ist eigentlich
vornehmlich der zahlungsverkehr zum teil
auch einmal die vermögensverwaltung und
dann wirklich auch das halten von
sparguthaben
da zittern das ist es eigentlich mehr
oder weniger sie haben keine hypotheken
von k s habe ich sechs sieben milliarden
um die sechs milliarden euro
die effektiv verwaltet werden und
vergleich ist das eine kleine
regionalbank oder eine relativ kleine
wir sprechen nicht über übermäßige über
über eine übermäßige anhäufung von
gelber oder über ein volumen dass es
irgendwo sozusagen das globale
finanzsystem kreisen muss der vatikan
mit seinem geld umgehen oder ohne wird's
nicht gehen
das ist der eine punkt und der andere
punkt ist der vatikan als seine globale
institution und sie haben dort
insbesondere auch tätigkeiten in
gebieten die wo krieg herrscht
die dann auch sanktionen ausgesetzt sind
neben syrien nehmen wir andere länder wo
eigentlich das sagen immer das normal
funktionierende weltliche finanzsystem
nicht unbedingt funktioniert weil sie
dort eigentlich gar keine möglichkeit
haben als finanzinstitut als solches
entsprechend dann auch einmal notwendige
gelder bereitstellen zu können
beziehungsweise die möglichkeit zu haben
unterstützen mitzubringen also zum
beispiel ein bischof der nach syrien
zurück reisen will oder eben sie an
afrika genannt das geht dann gar nicht
anders ist relativ problematisch und und
nochmals der vatikan ist eine solche
investition und hat dort auch ein
gewisses bedürfnis entsprechen
die möglichkeit zu haben finanz
transaktionen durchzuführen
durchzulassen
auch wenn wir uns verhalten hatten
müssen dass im vatikan kein finanzplatz
haben also sie haben keine irgendwo
keine börse oder
versicherungsunternehmen oder oder
treuhänder oder was auch immer
sie haben ganz spezifische
finanzaktivitäten die stattfinden die
vorgenommen werden
ob sie haben keinen kommerziellen
finanzplatz als solches und das hat auch
in der letzten oder in der vergangenheit
etwas zu gewissen missverständnissen
geführt jetzt sie haben vor wenigen
tagen die bilanz des letzten jahres eine
pressekonferenz vorgestellt da wurde zum
beispiel gesagt 544 transaktionen im
letzten jahr gemeldet davon werden 17
als verfahren geführt wie merken sie
jetzt a
da könnte was faul sein dass melden wir
als aufsichtsbehörde und nein das ist
eben der afrikanische bischof der graf
für sein hilfswerk da geld mit nach
afrika nimmt es bitte keine
unterstellung gegenüber afrikanischen
wie schon sein aber merken sie jetzt den
unterschied
nein die oder was geschieht ist dass das
in den letzten jahren gemacht haben
im bereich der des meldeverfahrens als
solches ist dass wir internationale
standards implementiert haben das
bedeutet jede finanzinstitution und im
vatikan hat man vornehmlich einerseits
aus
sondern auch die vermögensverwaltung des
apostolischen stuhles ist verpflichtet
seine kundenbeziehungen aber dann auch
die finanztransaktion als solches unter
die lupe zu nehmen zu überwachen und
dort wo mögliche hinweise zur geldwäsche
ich spreche sie wie tourismus
finanzierung weil das für uns
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen weniger
relevant ist aber insbesondere zur
geldwäsche zu möglichen vorteil einer
geldwäsche
dies verpflichtet uns das zu melden
und das ist dann und wenn wir
zurückgehen zum beispiel mit dem
afrikaner oder wenn sie irgendwo an
ein amerikanischer person haben oder
eine organisation oder wenn wir das
beispiel die grafikkarte wird dort
irgendwo eine bank bei einer an eine
kirche bauen oder of moscow stationen
und versucht dann sozusagen eine
entsprechende transaktion durchzuführen
oder geht zu mir und sagt ich brauche
eine million von meinem konto weil das
ist dort zusammen platziert worden
dann mag das möglicherweise sehen machen
aber es wahrscheinlich auch nicht weil
wahrscheinlich der betrag als solches zu
groß ist oder weil die entsprechenden
unterlagen fehlen oder was auch immer
und dann ist zum beispiel dass ihr
verpflichtet an und ein entsprechendes
verbandsmitteilung zu erstatten
und das ist dann an der behörde zu
verifizieren ob sozusagen diese
verdachtsmomente die uns mitgeteilt
worden sind ob wir die wie sozialen
fleisch an den knochen heranbringen und
sagen können okay das stimmt wirklich
etwas nicht und als wären die
fleißarbeit genau und das dort ist dann
auch eben zum beispiel die
internationale zusammenarbeit sehr sehr
zentral weil man dann schaut okay gibt
es dieses projekt überhaupt in afrika
also gibt es überhaupt dieses land wurde
aufgebaut worden ist oder gibt es
überhaupt zu zahlen dieses dieses
bauunternehmen dass zum beispiel der bau
der kirche durchführen soll
was kostet normalerweise zum beispiel am
bau einer kirche haben wir hier total
über die preise etc oder muss ich dann
wirklich so zahlen in eine spiegelung
der aktivitäten mit der realität als
solches
springt sie aufwendig sie haben sich
lorbeeren geholt vor ihrer tätigkeit im
vatikan im fürstentum liechtenstein
haben dort acht jahre in der anti
geldwäsche gearbeitet
erfolgreich wie kommt ein mann wie sie
der doch aus schaut als würde doch eher
von der bahnhofstrasse in zürich kommen
nun in den vatikan zu so einer aufgabe
ist bin ich die falsche person um diese
frage zu beantworten
ich wurde gefragt und habe dann auch mit
interesse ja gesagt und das interesse
sie haben ja in fribourg
louis also die jurisdiktion studiert
jura sie haben aber auch kirchenrecht
noch als ein letzter jahrgang
verpflichtend studiert das hilft ihm
jetzt wahrscheinlich oder als katholik
hat das eine rolle gespielt oder das
studium ist besonders eines kirchen nach
rechts ist schon eine weile her als man
da aber nein spaß beiseite die natürlich
irgendwo ein gewisses interesse einer
gewissen auseinandersetzung auch mit
diesen umständen und zurückgehend auf
ihre frage damals waren nicht nur
sozusagen liechtenstein ein teil meiner
aktivität sondern wir haben ja damals
auch versucht insbesondere die
internationale positionierung relativ
stark voran zu treiben in der
rhythmusgruppe also international
vernetzte anti geldwäsche genau und und
von daher hat man dann auch einmal bis
zum welt schaffen können oder schaffen
dürfen nämlich würde so sagen
um auch entsprechende arbeiten zuvor
nehmen und von daher kann dann eben
diese anfang auch verbunden sein mit
meinem anderen hintergrund
wo wir uns dann doch also von
verständnis für die institution braucht
es oder sie setzen ja nicht auf
verfolgen sondern auf vertrauen dass sie
den leuten erklären warum das so wie
steht ist nehme ich mal an dass das
korrekt ja also es ist ich glaube es ist
am besten beides also dass wenn es ein
bisschen zurück schauen wie das ganze
damals wirklich angefangen hat und auch
von den arbeiten die vorgenommen worden
sind
das ja nicht ich alleine oder es ist ja
nicht das geht auch hier nicht um mich
sondern es geht wirklich um die um die
arbeit als solches und um die leute
dieser auch mithelfen die auch wirklich
auch committed sind das ganze zu leben
und auch die entsprechende maßnahmen
einleiten zu können und die ersten mehr
oder weniger 4 6 monate haben sie auch
nichts gehört von mir oder von uns
damals das war wirklich wo wir oder wo
ich hingegangen bin und ich habe
versucht zu verstehen zu verstehen warum
es geht wer da wirklich was einerseits
macht wo die schwachstellen sind wir
vielleicht auch die stärken sind
insbesondere auch wo die players sind wo
einflussnahme auch generiert wird die
medien ausländischer behörden
aufsichtsbehörden etc
und wirklich versucht das alles irgendwo
in einen topf hinein zu werfen um für
mich selber einverständnis zu generieren
was braucht es um ein maßgeschneidertes
system entsprechend aufzusetzen und dann
auch umzusetzen
ihr habt doch gehandelt ich hab gesehen
4800 ungefähr kommt die abgeschlossen
wenn ich es richtig sehe von 19.000 es
aber doch fast ein viertel hatte aber
kräftig aufgeräumt
wir haben gearbeitet in den letzten
jahren das auf jeden fall und so auf auf
verschiedenen ebenen aber nochmals hier
wirklich gestützt auf ein
maßgeschneidertes system was wir immer
noch haben wo braucht es sozusagen neue
maßnahmen bzw
wo besteht auch ein bedürfnis dass man
klare zeichen setzt und ich denke das
zeichen hier ist dass man so proaktiv
wie möglich eigentlich die ganze sache
an die hand nehmen will
also spricht dass man hier ganz konkret
also ein frühwarnsystem auf setzt also
in ihrer behörde wurde auch
eingebrachten sie haben dann abhörwanze
gefunden
gibt es sonst widerstand wenn sie spüren
sie können davon ausgehen dass nicht
überall insbesondere mit seinem gewissen
wandel gibt wenn gewisse maßnahmen
eingeleitet werden dass nicht immer alle
super glücklich sind im großen und
ganzen glaube ich ist das ganze sehr
vernünftig über die bühne gegangen
und was für mich eigentlich immer das
entscheidende element gewesen essen auch
heute noch ist das der politische
support hier wirklich da ist und ich
glaube jetzt kann man sagen das ist nach
wie vor der fall und auch eines nicht
vergessen die ganze wasser heißt
politischer support das ist ja direkt
babs franziskus unterstellt oder ja das
ist so korrekt das ist eine sache das
anders dann aber auch oder das was man
eigentlich schafft und bearbeiten
das tut man ja nicht für sich selber
sondern das ist ultimativ für die
institution als solches insbesondere
auch zum schutz des vatikans des
heiligen stuhls als solches und hier
will man auch nicht irgendwo lisa man
tut es für die institution als solches
und wenn das dann auch entsprechend
aufgenommen wird und das dann auch
entsprechend umgesetzt wird dann merkt
man auch dass man das dann auch
motivation dass man eigentlich sozusagen
auf dem richtigen weg ist
das haben sie in interviews immer wieder
betont also das war die erste frage auch
bei der anfrage oder ihre bedingung der
support wie sie es jetzt nennen der muss
einfach gegeben sein
der papst bat franziskus greift der
selber ein wir kennen ihn als
tatkräftigen mann der einschaltete
marken setzt
spüren sie ihn schauen sie es nicht an
mir über papst franziskus zu sprechen
das einzige was ich sagen kann ist dass
der support und die unterstützung auf
jeden fall dort ist oder da ist wie das
dann sagen wir der ganze der ganze
alltag und auch die konkrete umsetzung
und die ganzen sachen laufen
es ist ein prozess ist ein austausch mit
verschiedenen personen und es geht auch
darum brücken zu bauen das geht auch
darum zu erklären warum machen wir das
überhaupt
sie dürfen eines nicht vergessen der
vatikan solches eigentlich auf zwei
ebenen dass eine wir die währungsunion
mit der mit europäischen union damit der
euro zone als offizielle währung im
vatikan verwendet werden kann hat zur
folge dass sich der vatikan verpflichtet
hat die ganzen europäischen geldwäsche
bekämpfung standards umzusetzen setzt
und drehte eu geldwäscherichtlinie neue
jetzt die vierte dass der eine punkt und
der zweite punkt ist dann auch dass man
sich vor paar jahren sozusagen
verpflichtet hat auch durch ein
internationales gremium ein mann wie sie
beim europarat nahm zwar nie wohl dass
man sich dort verpflichtet hat sozusagen
auch sein eigenes system überprüfen zu
lassen um zu schauen ob effektiv
sozusagen die internationalen standards
nicht nur umgesetzt werden sondern dass
sie wirklich auch effizient und effektiv
gelebt werden monnet war lobt sie sagt
aber auch sie würden zu wenige verfahren
anstrengen das liegt natürlich nicht in
ihren händen oder als aufsichtsbehörde
aber stimmen sie dem zu ich glaube die
verletzte moneyball bericht der im
dezember über die bühne gegangen ist ist
ein sehr sehr glaub ich
kurator bericht der auch glaube ich die
die lage als solche sehr gut wiedergibt
und sie dürfen eines nicht vergessen
woher wir gekommen sind ja bis sozusagen
bis ende 2010 gab es gar keine
geldwäsche gesetzgebung die neue
umfassende geldwäsche gesetzgebung wurde
2013 implementiert und umgesetzt also
vor ein paar wenigen jahren und das was
wir eigentlich machen hier nochmals ist
ein maßgeschneidertes system aufzusetzen
wo schritt für schritt für schritt nicht
nur aufgesetzt wird sondern auch gelebt
wird und sozusagen die strafe folgen die
scharfe form seite möglicherweise auch
mit entsprechenden verurteilungen
das ist eigentlich der letzte schritt
und das hat man ihm jetzt noch nicht
ganz mit erhalten
aber wir haben auch
in diesem jahr die ersten sozusagen
strafverfahren im zusammenhang mit
geldwäsche bekämpfung eingeleitet ich
hoffe selbstverständlich dass sich zu
viele sein werden aber dort dann auch
das entsprechende maßnahmen ganz konkret
vorgenommen worden sind
in einem punkt der boiler bin ich
aufmerksam noch geworden sie haben
erwähnt das wird auch in den papieren
in dem grundsatzpapier aufsichtsbehörde
immer wieder erwähnt geldwäsche
verhindern ein ziel das andere
finanzierung des terrorismus
wir haben immer gedacht der vatikan wird
oft genau das mögliches angriffsziel des
terrorismus jetzt sagen sie aber wie
könnt ihr dann dass sein dass der
vatikan mithilft terrorismus zu
finanzieren was ich immer gesagt habe
ist dass wir es eher ausschließen oder
was sozusagen der vatikan missbraucht
wird sozusagen für mögliche terrorismus
finanzierungsaktivitäten ganz einfachen
grund zusammen
der zugang zu den finanzinstitutionen im
vatikan ist äußerst eingeschränkt und
sowie die entsprechenden verwendung
läuft dieser gebe dann für
terroristische aktivitäten verwendet
werden könnten oder so wir haben
zumindest bis zum heutigen zeitpunkt
keine hinweise gehabt dass dies
entsprechend gelebt oder gelebt werden
würde das andere ist dann eine mögliche
terrorismus gefahr eines anschlages oder
was auch immer wir müssen hier wirklich
differenzieren einerseits die
finanzierung und andererseits wirklich
selber ziel zu sein
das heißt wer sich die verstehe gelder
die brauerei zwecke bestimmt sind
könnten missbraucht werden
über eben ein konto zum beispiel der
sogenannten vatikanbank für die
finanzierung von terrorismus
beim islamischen standorte wo geht's
denn da konkret bin eben nochmal sowie
gestützt auf die erkenntnisse die wir
zum heutigen zeitpunkt haben gehen davon
aus dass dies gerade nicht da ist
oder und das dort eigentlich eine sehr
beschränkte verwundbarkeit legt
nichtsdestotrotz schauen wir darauf
jetzt sind die banker sind den letzten
monaten groß in den medien gewesen
ich habe eigentlich nie was wahrgenommen
panama papers und vatikan liege ich da
falsch gibt es da zusammenhänge lassen
wir uns überraschen hoffentlich positive
das spricht dass es nicht der fall ist
schauen sie werden sehen in den nächsten
wochen wenn dann auch noch mehr
informationen auch aufgedeckt werden
wenn noch mehr informationen dann auch
der öffentlichkeit zu getan werden ich
glaube dass ein wichtiger punkt ist ja
auch so ein bisschen im zusammenhang mit
den ganzen panama papers auch eine
gewisse vorverurteilung
auch seitens der medien die hier
stattfindet wenn wir ein bisschen
genauer hineinschauen ist ja nicht so
dass sämtliche strukturen oder sie
wollen auch diese auf strukturen oder
diese diese trasse foundations oder was
weiß ich dass die illegal wären sondern
das sind nicht nur in panama auch in
vielen anderen institutionen
das sind sozusagen strukturen die
gestützt auf einen rechtlichen rahmen
aufgesetzt weil sie unterscheidung
wurden ja immer wieder betont es könnte
aber noch was kommt heißt das mit
anderen worten wie gesagt ich bin immer
vorsichtig bei solchen aussagen
wir haben zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
unbedingt hinweis darauf also ich hoffe
auch dass dass das nicht der fall sein
wird oder wenn es der farbe ist dass man
das auch in entsprechenden kontext
stellen kann also spricht dass wir hier
wirklich auch über legitimes business
oder über legitim aktivitäten sprechen
können sollte dies nicht der fall sein
haben wir instrumente um das
entsprechend an die hand zu nehmen
was interessiert was motiviert diesen
rönne brüllen etwas 13 ist es
ein sinn für gerechtigkeit oder was was
sind verschiedene sachen das eine ist
mitzuhelfen und es wirklich an
mitzuhelfen etwas zu gestalten etwas
auszusetzen
ein system zu schaffen dann ist das eine
das anders dann auch zu dienen
es ist glaube ich die wenn wir den
vatikan als solches nehmen hat auch eine
andere verantwortung wenn sie irgendwo
finanzinstitutionen in der welt nehmen
dann haben wir eine gewisse
verantwortung über aufsichtsbehörden
vielleicht gegenüber den den aktionären
dem eigenen personal das schauen dass
sie nicht entlassen werden etc
aber es einander motivation dahinter
denn hier haben sie vielmehr haben sie
eine verantwortung gegenüber 1,213
milliarden gläubigen wo sie auch an der
werte mit hineinbringen wo sie auch das
was vorhin gesagt ein frühwarnsystem zu
schaffen ja sie haben eine andere
verantwortung hier der sie gerecht
werden müssen
sie haben ein anderes werte denken dass
seite stecken und das ist denke ich
antrieb genug das finde ich sehr
interessant dass sie das jetzt so zum
schluss dieses gesprächs in den
vordergrund rücken ich habe hier nämlich
bücher mitgebracht von andreas englisch
oder gianluigi nuzzi alles muss ans
licht in bücher die genau diese
diskrepanz eigentlich letztlich
aufzeigen dass eine institution die sich
eben für moralische werte einsetzt
einsetzen sollte dann auch mit solchen
machenschaften im finanziellen bereich
verbunden wird eine bull hat wenn sie im
vatikan mal zu ende geht was sind die
perspektiven wo wird es für sie
weitergehen was wird sie reizen was für
eine aufgabe könnte noch kommen
ich beschäftige momentan genug noch mit
sammer mit den herausforderungen seitens
des vatikans
was die zukunft bringen wird werden wir
sehen
wir werden sehen wir sind gespannt hat
sie dank für das gespräch
meine brille hat dann können
mit der juni geht es los dann beginnt
die fußball em in frankreich rabbiner
hochschulpfarrer christoph siegrist und
imam muris pekovic nehmen daran nicht
teil
doch kicken tun sie sehr wohl im fc
religionen in zürich und den stellen wir
ihn jetzt vor schönen sonntag